- So Representative Eric Swalwell
has filed suit against former
President Donald Trump,
for basically inciting a riot.
He has filed a civil suit
to try and get damages
for all of the things that he claims
that President Trump did
as a result of January 6th.
Now, this lawsuit is not on great footing
and is probably going to get dismissed
for several different reasons.
First, presidents have absolute immunity
from all civil actions taken
as a result of official
acts while president.
The case law is pretty
much settled on this point,
you cannot civilly sue a former president
for actions that they took
that were part of their official duties.
It appears that a
prosecutor could go after
a former president for
criminal actions taken
but not a civil suit.
And additionally,
this lawsuit would have
to get over the hurdle
to prove that President
Trump committed incitement
that his words were not
protected by the First Amendment.
And that is likely to
be dispositive as well.
So this lawsuit is probably
not going anywhere.
So if you're Eric Swalwell,
I won't see you in court,
but if you don't subscribe,
I will see you in court.